بالنسبة لمحبي الرياضة ،
كانت البرتغال وجهة لا بد من زيارتها
لعقود من الزمن ، حيث كانت المرافق
الرائعة والمناخ الرائع تجتذب الهواة
والمحترفين على حد سواء ، كما أنها كانت
المكان الذي وقعت فيه لأول مرة في حب
لعبة الجولف في عطلة عائلية ، فقد أحبها من
الضربة الأولى
أو  ربما يكون المركز العاشر
الواقع في الغارف ، يجتذب كيندر
ديلاجو الزوار من جميع أنحاء
العالم لسنوات هذا العام ، حيث يحتفل هذا العام
بالذكرى الخمسين لتأسيسه ، وهو
إنجاز كبير في سوق شديد
التنافسية ،
ولحسن الحظ لدينا ماض رائع وله
ماضٍ بدأ
برؤية رائعة
، رؤية كانت سابقة بشكل جيد وحقيقي على
وقت أي شخص آخر
بالإضافة إلى ملاعب الجولف ، استثمر الأشخاص الذين
يقفون وراء كينتا أيضًا في
فندق والعديد من المطاعم ،
وهناك المزيد لتعرفه على مدار السنوات
الماضية.  لقد كنا دائمًا في
هذه الرحلة من التحسين المستمر والتحسين
المستمر في كل ما
نقوم به من معاييرنا وخدمتنا
ثم دي  العيش في
شيء فريد من نوعه وأنت تعلم
أن هذا هو ما نفخر به جدًا
على مدار
الخمسين عامًا القادمة وبالتأكيد في المدى الأقصر
خلال الخمس أو الست المقبلة ، لدينا
بعض الخطط الرائعة
للتركيز على ما لدينا  كان يقوم به
على مدار السنوات الماضية ، وهذا
يقدم المزيد من المنتجات الفريدة التي
لا تزال في نطاق عالي وحصري ،
وهناك تأثير إيرلندي قوي في
كينتا ، كابتن كأس ريدر السابق ، بول
ماكجينلي ، لديه أكاديمية خاصة به في الموقع
فوق الهدف ، تحصل على نقطة واحدة
حسنًا ، هذه هي
الأكاديمية الموجودة في ميدان القيادة في King to
delago ، لدينا 28 مكانًا
في ميدان القيادة للأشخاص لضرب
الكرات وهذا هو
مركز تركيب متخصص حيث يمكننا قياس
الأشخاص للأندية التي حصلت على كل
ما هو جديد.  المعدات تختبر
تقلباتهم وتساعدهم بشكل عام في الحصول
على الأندية المناسبة في أيديهم
، كما يتم تشجيع الشباب
على ممارسة الرياضة منذ سن مبكرة
بينما لا يزالون يشحذون
مهاراتهم التي تجلبها الدورات والمرافق المعروضة
في تدفق مستمر لأفضل لاعبي العالم
[موسيقى]
على وضع أخضر فوق ميدان القيادة ، كان
أحد كبار
المحترفين في البرتغال يمر
بخطواته قبل الشروع في جولة تدريب
ولد وترعرع في هذه المنطقة ، حيث يقول إن
الجولف جزء لا يتجزأ من
نشأ هنا
إذا رأيت ملاعب جولف في جميع أنحاء
الجرف ملاعب غولف جميلة ، لدينا
ساحل جميل ، نعم إنه جزء كبير من
نظامنا الاقتصادي ،
ومن الرائع
أن تعيش بجوار هذه
المرافق الجميلة ، فالطقس مثالي
للجولف  الطعام رائع ، فأنت
بجوار المحيط مباشرةً ، لذا فمن المثالي للعائلات
أن تأتي هنا وتلعب الجولف واستمتع
بالمرافق الجميلة التي تقدمها quinto lagu
هنا ، وأعتقد أنها مصممة لأه
عائلة من جميع النواحي تعرف أن لديك
أنشطة أطفالك
لديك أشياء للقيام بها
إلى جانب الجولف أيضًا ، لكن الجولف هو
الرياضة الرئيسية هنا ، حيث يمكن
للاعبي الجولف من جميع القدرات الاستمتاع
بالحرم الجامعي ، وهو مرفق أصبح سريعًا
سببًا قائمًا بذاته لزيارة k  بين
بعض أفضل فرق كرة القدم في أوروبا
بالإضافة إلى فريق الرجبي الأيرلندي الذي
يحتل المرتبة الأولى حاليًا في العالم ،
استفادوا من
ملعب التدريب الذي تم الاحتفاظ به تمامًا والصالة الرياضية التي تأتي
معها ،
وقد تطور الحرم الجامعي أو كوينسي
ديلاغو مما كان في الأساس
منتجع قائم على الجولف في غضون ساعة واحدة
لقضاء عطلة عائلية متعددة الرياضات ووجهة للمعيشة ، لذلك
لدينا الآن مع الحرم الجامعي هنا
لدينا الفرصة لمرافق عالية الأداء
للتدريب على التجديف الثلاثي ،
وركوب الدراجات ، واللياقة البدنية ، والرجبي ،
والسباحة ، يمكننا توفيرها تقريبًا
مهما كانت الاحتياجات ، فهو يحتوي على
كل ما تحتاجه الآن سواء كان ذلك
لمجرد القدوم في عطلة أو تريد
المجيء إلى هنا للقيام ببعض التدريب المحدد
أو تريد
إحضار فريق لبناء فريق أو تدريب عالي الأداء
نود أن نقدمه لنخبة
مرافق مهما كان مستوى
الشخص الموجود هنا سواء كنت
أفضل لاعب غولف أو مجرد شخص
يستمتع بجولة غولف مع صديق جيد
في حالة الطقس الأفضل في هذا الجزء من
البرتغال ، هناك حقًا شيء للجميع
[موسيقى]